[Applause]
social media footage shows crowds
protesting in front of the offices of
the chinese real estate developer
evergrand
evergrand is
one of china's biggest property
developers it has the biggest sales
in terms of property sales in china in
recent days security has been stepped up
outside its headquarters as the
struggling company faces complaints from
small investors unpaid suppliers and
people unhappy that the homes that they
purchase haven't yet been completed
in total everground owes more than 300
billion dollars it's one of the most
indebted companies in the world
evergrand borrowed a lot of money what
we call offshore in international
financial markets and it's probably not
going to pay it back evergren's massive
debt problem has rippled out into global
markets with the s p 500 seeing big
swings
beyond the potential default
international investors are particularly
worried about what may happen next as a
big chunk of china's economy is linked
to real estate if evergreen fails and
drags down the whole property sector
people worry if chinese economy could
develop
at high speed
as it did in the past years more bullish
investors think china could find a way
to contain the fallout but others are
less certain that this can be safely
diffused
this one company has got markets on edge
and its struggles could have big
repercussions for global investors
in recent months evergrant
has been caught into one of the largest
crisis in its history for years
everground raised a lot of its cash by
borrowing billions of dollars from banks
and investors and pre-selling unfinished
apartments so that it could amass more
land and develop projects in over 200
chinese cities
it has some 800 projects underway
but this year its shares have lost about
80 of their value in just a few months
problems started for the company when
pandemic lockdowns hurt property sales
and when chinese authorities said they
wanted to fight speculation in real
estate and announced rules that barred
everground from taking on new debt many
of its construction projects
all over china
has stopped
it started to face mounting pressure
complaints and protests from
suppliers contractors home buyers and
small investors all over the country
in this footage from chinese social
media people can be seen asking for
compensation the wall street journal
couldn't determine the author of the
video or the exact date of this
particular protest and this clip has
since been taken down
these photos show small investors being
surrounded by security as they tried to
enter the company's headquarters in
shenzhen
evergrande has repeatedly said that it
would try to reimburse people and resume
construction
evergrand's struggles are raising
questions over china's property market
evergren is such a big player on china's
property industry the property industry
account for about
25 of the total economy so
if growth in that sector is eroded
we will see the macro economy under big
challenges in a memo on september 21st
everground's chairman acknowledged the
issues that the company faces but vowed
to push through the pain
wall street journal reporting found that
chinese authorities have asked local
governments to contain the potential
downfall of everground
but the government has been reluctant to
bail it out
and global investors are watching to see
how this could affect this year's market
rally
the stock market has gone up a ton since
the pandemic especially in the u.s and
there's this sense of what can make
things go higher and what could go wrong
some investors think letting everground
fail would be a sign that china is
serious about reducing debt in the
economy people we talked to widely
believe beijing won't step in to protect
shareholders or bond holders this time
but they might take some actions if they
see
social unrest spread or if they see
financial markets being void heavily by
evergreen
[Music]